I want a slightly more substantively
address the Republican primary polling
that's out there right now I got a
handful of emails from people in the
audience nice people like you
um who said you know David I see that
Trump's winning a bunch of polls and
DeSantis is winning a couple this is the
the primary polling of course
does this really matter at this point in
time and that's more or less exactly the
right question that should be asked in
other words the critical questions are
how accurate are presidential primary
polls in March of the year before the
election and secondly is there something
special this time around that might make
polling more or less relevant regardless
of how accurate polling tends to be at
this point in an election cycle so let's
go through this step by step first of
all it Remains the case that Trump is
ahead of DeSantis in most 2024 primary
polling
and the uh higher rated the pollster
generally speaking the more Trump seems
to be winning by we'll look at a couple
of examples here the latest poll is from
Quinnipiac University that's an a-minus
rated pollster a very good pollster they
have Trump plus 11 against DeSantis in a
head-to-head matchup and Trump plus 14
against DeSantis in a multi-way match-up
that trend is holding in basically every
poll which is Trump does better against
DeSantis when there are more options why
well because Nikki Haley takes a little
more from DeSantis than she does from
Trump and Pence takes a little more from
DeSantis than Trump and so what you get
is when you include more candidates
Trump is winning by more morning consult
poll a multi-way poll has Trump plus 24
over DeSantis that's a B minus rated
pollster and then you have the CNN SSRS
poll that's a c plus rated pollster that
one does have DeSantis plus two against
Trump in a multi-way race it also gives
Pence
which is you know I don't know that I
believe Mike Pence has six percent
support right now but that this is the
whole point of looking at a variety of
polls and then you look at an A minus
rated PPP poll from uh roughly a week
ago
and that one has Trump plus eight in a
head-to-head matchup and Trump plus 18
in a multi-way match-up great so today's
polling Trump generally doing better
than DeSantis the more can that it's
there are the better Trump does fine the
next question is
how accurate
the accurate is not the right word
how reliably does the leader in these
polls in March of the year before the
primary
uh end up actually winning the primary
or to put it another way is it normal
that whoever is leading in March of the
year before ends up being the nominee
and the answer is it's not that common
or put a different way it's pretty
common that whoever's waiting at this
point doesn't actually end up winning
I'll give you some examples if you look
at the polling from the Republican
primary in 2016 meaning March of 2015.
Trump was not winning in March of 2015
and he was ultimately the nominee in
2016. Barack Obama was not winning in
March of 2007 but he was eventually the
Democratic nominee in 2008. Rudy
Giuliani was leading in March of 2007 he
was not the 2008 Republican nominee it
was of course the late John McCain so
there are many such examples like this
so the part two of our investigation is
it's really common that winning in March
of the year before doesn't really tell
us who's eventually going to win and
then we get to the third part of the
question
is there something special or different
this time around that might make all of
this stuff very very different or
particularly irrelevant and the answer
is yeah sorta it is not typical that you
have running in a contested primary
a candidate who was previously the
president
lost re-election and is then running
again that's not normal and so I'll tell
you right up front I have no idea what
the impact of that would be on the
accuracy of polling data in terms of
being reflective of the eventual outcome
in March of 2023 for a 2004 election so
that in my mind is the full story we've
considered all the factors what is the
polling how much does polling at this
point in time matter and are there
special circumstances affecting this
election the answer being yes that's the
totality of the polling story
and with that context we can now
evaluate future polls Republicans are
endorsing Ron DeSantis for president
even though he's not actually running
yet this is a very interesting situation
is it unique though we'll answer that
question in a moment first here is a
video from a couple of weeks ago from
Jeb Bush a former governor of Florida
who uh says he likes DeSantis even
though DeSantis is not at this point in
time a candidate I think it's pretty
remarkable and he hasn't declared yet
many in the Republican Party hope
he soon will
as this run desantis's opportunity to
run for higher office I think it is he's
been a really effective Governor he's
young I think we're on the verge of a
generational change in our politics I
kind of hope so I think it's time for a
more forward-leaning future oriented uh
conversation or Politics as well which
has made him should he choose to run for
the president a serious contender in
Republican politics and who better to do
it than someone who's been outside of
Washington who's governed effectively
who I think has shown that Florida could
be a model for the future of our country
yeah now remember Florida's rankings are
very mediocre ranked between 20th and
30th and most indicators as I told you
but put that aside for a second that
sounded like a pretty full-throated
endorsement by Jeb Bush of Ronda santis
he later said I was praising not
endorsing DeSantis but he is clearly
making public statements that he likes
DeSantis for president even though
DeSantis is not actually a candidate yet
we have another example of this
Republican chip Roy has now in endorse
Ron DeSantis for president putting out a
statement uh two days ago saying the
next president of the uh well it's
called Ron DeSantis for president and he
says the next president of the United
States must be a vibrant and energetic
leader
with the faith vision and courage to
chart a new course America needs a
leader who will truly defend her and
empower the people against the
destructive force of unrestrained
government and corporate excess
profligate spending and woke cultural
indoctrination that leader says chip Roy
is Ron Florida Governor Ron DeSantis a
man of conviction a man who puts his
faith in God first as a dedicated
husband and father he grew up a
blue-collar kid who worked hard got a
great education and used it immediately
to serve his country he loves America
unapologetically but loves freedom and
the rule of law even more with the
courage to fight for both yeah not the
freedom for teachers to teach what they
determine is best to teach not the
freedom for Disney to support the causes
it wants to support without risking
losing it yeah you you guys it's a very
uh short-sighted version of Freedom so
is it normal or common for
non-candidates to be endorsed is this
something we've seen in the history of
the United States we've seen it a few
times it's not the most common thing
in 1924
former president Teddy Roosevelt was
endorsed for the presidency by the
Progressive Party despite the fact that
he had not announced his candidacy and
Roosevelt declined the nomination but it
certainly raised the profile of the
Progressive Party in 1960 Dwight D
Eisenhower endorsed vice president
Richard Nixon for the Republican
nomination Nixon at that point had not
formally announced his candidacy and
then in 2020 former president Barack
Obama endorsed Joe Biden even though at
that point Biden had also not officially
announced but it was one of these
situations where it was pretty clear and
written on the wall that an announcement
was forthcoming so long story short it
is not super common
to see someone who isn't running
endorsed and when we see them endorsed
it is often the case that they are close
to an announcement so do I believe
DeSantis will announce or as some of you
have written to me do I think the
scientists will use this as a waiting
game and end up sitting aside until 2028
I lean towards the scientists will run
24 but I'm still very much open to the
idea that I'm wrong why because I'm
wrong all the time in my predictions and
so I don't I have zero confidence in any
of my own predictions I want to look at
a clip of our friend Walter Masterson
Walter Masterson went to
uh CPAC and he did some really
interesting interviews and this is one
that is uniquely stupid in a way
this is a trump supporter that Walter
interviewed
and one of the things Walter does at
these events is he pretends to be on
their side like I think here he's
wearing an ultra Maga shirt and you know
he pretends to be on their side and one
of the things that happens with these
folks when you pretend to be on their
site is you can get him to agree to
almost anything because they don't
really have any actual beliefs that they
truly understand they just want to feel
correct here is a trump supporter who
says she is against critical race Theory
but she wants more black history to be
taught of course ignoring the reality
that what they call critical race Theory
often is just teaching black history
take a look at this gold mine when I get
very aggravated because I notice the
folks who push CRT do not seem to take
the time to teach about Frederick
Douglass who was a great black founding
father they have erased the work of
early black people in this country
Frederick Douglass well you know what
when they want to teach that they're
accused of teaching critical race Theory
um uh Harriet Tubman many of these
things we're not taught about them and
they're full uh capacity so what we need
to do is we need to get rid of the CRT
nonsense and start teaching more about
what Harriet Tubman Frederick Douglass
John Brown the person who uh stole the
Confederate ship W.E.B DuBois Marcus
Garvey yeah Malcolm X Martin Luther King
yeah Farrakhan I mean you know
oh that's great she's nodding about
Farrakhan she has no clue who some of
these people are you all you all can
tell I'm sure it's crazy it is a robbery
of both black and white children to not
teach that history because black
children should be knowing that there
were great black leaders that they can
identify with and uh yeah it's like no
one none of these kids know who Marcus
Garvey is yeah exactly
this this is this is really really
stunning stuff and it's stunning for a
number of different reasons
um this is very similar to I hate
Obamacare oh okay what about the
Affordable Care Act that's fine right
but they're the exact same thing this is
very similar to
get the government the hell out of my
medicare don't touch it oh but Medicare
is a government Health Care Program this
is slightly different but still similar
to Sharia law is bad and we've got to
keep it out of the United States when
it's Muslim Sharia law but a Christian
version of that Sharia law would
actually be fine because the founding
fathers were Christian or whatever the
case may be this really is something
else and this is part of why there's no
talking these people out of these
beliefs really scary stuff very nice job
by Walter Masterson there the David
packman show is a community funded
program that means you if you listen to
the show if you watch Clips or listen on
the radio or watch on TV or whatever the
case may be you were the type of person
in that you are a person who funds our
program you can sign up at
joinpakman.com we've got great
membership perks including the
commercial free show every single day
hours before we publish it for others
what a bet what what is better than just
getting something other people aren't
right no I'm kidding but in all
seriousness we do make that a member
benefit uh the bonus show and so many
other great things sign up at
joinpakman.com and it is a beautiful day
when people sign up let's hear from
people in the audience and by that I
mean we take calls via Discord you can
find our Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord
we start today with Bishop from Kentucky
Bishop from Kentucky welcome to the
program uh let me know what's on your
mind today what's going on
hello yeah you're on the air
okay
um today I was wondering I have a little
bit of like an ethical question or moral
question do you think it's ever
justifiable and I guess the question
will differ morally and ethically do you
think it's ever justifiable for a nation
to ever want an ethno State because I
know Nations like Israel exist Nations
like um Japan exists they have different
like policies obviously but they kind of
advocate for the same thing like do you
think that's ever Justified or no
uh
uh I've never heard the question really
asked that way I mean I I I don't know
what the follow-up would be but if
literally as asked is it justifiable
for a people to want an ethno state are
there circumstances that would make
wanting an ethno State justifiable sure
we may agree or disagree as to whether
the the desire is based in reality but
sure it's valid to want that
yeah
more so it's kind of like long term it's
just like a realistic
um
is it realistic to like have one or
maintain one I think is probably a
better question I think the future will
because I mean I I don't I don't know I
mean I think it's you know when you
consider all sorts of different factors
like globalization modernity the decline
of religion all these different things I
think it's a predictive question is it
possible for an ethno state to persist I
think the other thing that's important
to include in this discussion is you
know eventually Rome fell so when we say
about indefinitely what do we really
mean nothing's real nothing has lasted
indefinitely so far and it's possible
nothing will last indefinitely
yeah of course that's true to consider I
was kind of just um curious as to
whether or not you thought just just at
the clear morally just like that's
something I would have like bounce off
of you to see if you had any thoughts on
it sure all right well I appreciate the
call
okay thank you David all right there
goes Bishop from Kentucky let's go next
to
how about uh Chris from Texas Chris from
Texas welcome to the show what's on your
mind today
all right can you hear me right now yes
I can
I have two questions I guess we're
regarding healthcare okay
my first question is regarding the like
like drug shortage is that right now I'm
just wondering
why hasn't like Biden been like more
restrictive on like Controlled
Substances such like for Adderall right
now given that it's kind of hurting a
lot of people right now I don't know
that I have a specific answer as to why
he hasn't I mean I just think it it's
clearly not a priority he didn't
campaign on it he didn't pretend that
that was going to be his big Focus so I
don't I don't I know you may be looking
for a different type of answer but I
just don't think that he's made it a
priority
yeah because I mean from what I've heard
right now is he's actually restricting
the levels of it like Adderall
production right now and other control
like other c2s for like ADHD right now
I'm not aware of what Biden restricting
Adderall production I haven't read about
that
um for like from the D from the DEA
let's see he he's certainly working what
I'm reading is that the Biden through
the DEA are looking at limiting
prescribing but that the underlying
reason may be more limited production
but I'm not seeing that Biden is the
reason for the limited production
okay so I guess in that case I'm
probably maybe over emphasizing the
abiding with the DEA in that regard yeah
it could be
okay my next question is I remember
watching a video one time a long time
ago about Healthcare in the United
States and like there's a there was a
city I think in Montana Montana called
Libby
that had like some kind of Health Health
crisis that ultimately led to this to
Obama like I think around 2008 leading
to him uh giving us help giving that
that City you know Universal Health Care
so I believe it it was asbestos right
yeah I think so yeah
do you think it's possible I mean I mean
I mean granted the Supreme Court's
pretty much stacked right now in
conservatives favor do you think it's
possible Biden would ever be able to
Biden or another Democrat in the future
would be able to do an executive order
to try to mandate health care that would
be a great overscope of the government
to mandate it in what way
uh I guess kind of like using the same
logic that that Libby Libby Montana had
to give it it's its citizens their
health care I don't think so so here's
the thing here this is a complicated
issue because the president is the
president and is connected to the
federal government and right now we have
some federal health care programs like
for example Medicare is federal but
administered at the state level Medicaid
I'm sorry Medicaid's the state level one
medication
is the federal yes it but it's still
administered at the state level so let
me see if I can let's forget everything
I was saying because we kind of got
derailed I think the point here is Joe
Biden I don't believe would be able to
mandate that states have to provide
Health Care directly like I don't think
Joe Biden would be able to say Vermont
must have single-payer health care which
Vermont was considering at one point in
time I believe that the most direct way
for a president to expand Health Care
nationally would be to lower the age at
which you can get Medicare
or to raise the income at which you can
get Medicaid although states have to
accept that those would be the most
legally simple ways for a president to
expand Access to Health Care
yeah I guess I guess you're right so but
I guess the other issue is that like
would be like with State states trying
to States like Texas trying to sabotage
a Medicaid expansion
right that's that's the issue you can't
there were States who was part of
Obamacare just declined the Medicaid
expansion and so the question then
becomes can the president mandate that
states have to do the Medicaid expansion
I don't know it's a legal question I
just don't have the answer
yeah all right thanks for the time David
all right Chris from Texas great to hear
from you why don't we go next to oh I
don't know how about Seth from Nebraska
Seth welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
Seth from Nebraska please accept my
invitation sir if you would like to talk
to me
Seth welcome
Seth you're on but I'm not hearing you
one opportunity you gotta change your
audio device to one that works
all right and there goes Seth from
Nebraska how about uh Jamie from South
Dakota Jamie from South Dakota welcome
to the program what is on your mind
today Jamie
hello David can you hear me yes I can
okay I had a question about the uh
United States and NATO okay so high blue
so I believe that uh Joe Biden has done
a good job uh with like not sending uh
U.S troops but providing Aid and keeping
the US and the EU cohesively together
okay but I was just wondering what you
thought of like the pro uh the
anti-ukraine or pro-putin sentiment
um like from like Tucker Carlson or uh
some Republicans and how that could
damage our uh relationship with the EU
well moving forward on on a personal
level I find the soft Putin defenses
pretty vile and I don't care who's doing
them because as a progressive
anti-authoritarian I'm not big on
authoritarian autocrats so I'm not big
on Putin and I'm not big on duterte and
I'm not big on erdogan or bolsonaro or
so as a matter of principle I disagree
now you're going to the next layer which
is important to do which is
if they got their way in terms of if
American policy more closely mirrored
Tucker's view rather than what we have
what would that do for our alliances and
relationships and I think it would be
hugely damaging I think it would it
would affiliate us with the worst of the
global authoritarian autocrats it would
alienate us from many of our historical
allies where we share more values we
don't necessarily share all values but
we share more so I think it would be
disastrous politically in that way as
well
yes exactly that's what I think as well
yeah uh thank you for taking my question
David what's it what's it like in South
Dakota tell me do you live rurally or in
a city
I live rurally in South Dakota how how
rural give me a sense
uh we have uh 2500 people wow okay 25
000 people 25 000 people oh 25 000. oh
that's not that small
yep so we're about the third uh most
populated city in the state and it's uh
it's pretty conservative
um a little a little too much now if you
wanted for example to fly somewhere far
away let's say you wanted to fly to
Europe how close is the airport you
would drive to to start that trip
um
well we have a airport in in town but
the biggest city that you'd go for like
a flight like that would be Sioux Falls
and it's three hours away okay so you
would but I'm guessing like can you get
to Chicago from where you live from that
small airport no no oh yeah the only
airport you uh our airport only goes to
uh Minneapolis Minnesota oh okay well
but so then you can fly to Minneapolis
and then get like a Delta flight to
Europe so that's not that bad actually
that's pretty well connected
yep okay all right very good well just
curious Jamie from South Dakota great to
hear from you hope you have a good day
David all right you two have a good one
appreciate it just a reminder to
everybody who wants to talk to me if you
have like an obvious nickname or just a
name and no location in your nickname
that I see you're not gonna get called
on the format is name and where you're
calling from or where you're calling
from and your name or whatever obviously
I don't know if it's your real name but
if it's like a vulgar joke rather than a
plausible name you're also not going to
get called on just so people know let's
go next to Brian from Ireland who is
also a website member Brian thank you
for being a member on the website
you're coming through beautifully
great
um yeah thanks for having me on again
um pleasure I've been enjoying some of
your videos recently on the uh the CPAC
you know it's kind of a a thing I've not
been majorly aware of over the side
Atlantic for
um most of its existence so it's quite
horrifying isn't it
it is but I will say a couple of the
videos you put up were
some of the ones I've left the more
stats yeah since joining the channel
like the the Ben Carson one
um where he was you know he was talking
about pretty
uh deep stuff it's on the dead bodies on
the beaches yes and the music place oh
my God oh my God it is it is quite
incredible yeah
it was hilarious and just one more
example was the um
the Kimberly Guilfoyle you know I I was
only listening on the podcast so I
didn't see the video you were talking
about how the room only had 30 people or
whatever but yeah when when they started
cheering it was very clear that there
was barely anyone yes it was it really I
mean they really are parodies of
themselves it's it's stunning stuff
but a question on that then um you know
as I said I don't know a huge amount
about CPAC so just could you give me an
overview of how influential is it on on
Modern American politics like is it
likely to move the needle in any way in
Trump's favor or will it have very
little impact on the course I don't
think it will impact no because here's
the thing CPAC has increasingly become
a Maga event where people like Mitt
Romney and Paul Ryan and others they
just don't go it's not that they go but
the the needle moves against them they
just don't even attend so CPAC has
become like a self-selected group of
Republicans that are already part of the
the crazy Maga movement so quite frankly
I don't believe CPAC has the the CPAC we
had two weeks ago I think has no impact
on who is going to be the Republican
nominee
okay yeah and I kind of got that Vibe
especially especially with the small
audiences as we were talking about but
yeah yeah it's quite empathetic in a way
at the very least did you get any new
um fun soundboard clips for your for
your you know I think we added um I
don't know that we got anything from we
should we should look at the top clips
and pull some clips for the sound board
I think that would be a good idea
yeah and of course it's a lovely new
benefit for members as well absolutely
you get that now do you what do you use
the member sound board for out of
curiosity
well I haven't really used it for
anything functional I've just been kind
of enjoying going through it and yeah
you know it's kind of surprising my
fiance at times just putting out uh uh
at the trumpser compilation or whatever
you know it's good fun it's not exactly
a productivity tool we can say no I yeah
all right Brian from Ireland appreciate
hearing from you again
thanks a lot tip all right there it goes
Brian from Ireland let's take just the
quickest of breaks and get back and talk
to more people on Discord if you're
waiting to talk to me
don't go anywhere because we're coming
right back to Discord in a moment
for some more people via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord we have so many people who want
to chat but we have to pick someone to
talk to and we are next going to be
going to Rick from Southeast Texas Rick
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
Rick sir please unmute
hey David good afternoon thank you sir
sir we do appreciate it my pleasure um
David my uh my question for you today is
I I have trouble with cognitive
dissonance between
you know there's a I don't want to get
into details and I don't want to kick to
you get you kicked off your your radio
Partners but there's certain groups of
people that I watch that are displayed
as Republicans but do very very good
things for society I'll just say it's
relating to to children and
anti-abuse I'll keep it at that
um but what Rick I don't know what
you're talking about
well so let me let me rephrase there's a
group of people that
um investigate uh child child uh
Predators okay and they go after they go
after them online kind of a Chris Hansen
style I'm sure you've heard of them oh
these are the videos I see on Tick Tock
where like someone shows up at a
Chick-fil-A and someone with a camera
goes up to like a 38 year old who's
there to meet a 14 year old girl and
they confront them in public or whatever
absolutely yeah I see dangerous to do
certainly I think law enforcement would
say you probably shouldn't do it but
certainly I've seen it done I've seen it
done
yes of course at their at their own risk
but yeah my question is they're they're
doing good clearly so let me say this
they have good intentions right and so
my question is when these kind of people
come out later and say I'm very you know
public and very role-like and you know
how do you best deal with wanting to
support that but also not wanting to
follow along with their baggage so
what's a safe way to do that in your
opinion kind of like listen here's
here's the thing Rick here's the thing
it's not like the Republicans are
Against Child predators and the
Democrats are for them I mean I think
what you're talking about is there's
like a small subset of the vast majority
of the population that's against child
predators that creates a very particular
video based on these stings that are
done uh but that doesn't mean that it's
representative of right-wing views
rather than left-wing views right I mean
sort of like saying like hey you know
what I don't know we have such
differences about what the tax rate
should be but I find that Republicans
and Democrats all breathe air as well
well okay but fine but so that's not
really a distinguishing characteristic
so the way I would see it is if Utah
talk to just about any Republican or
just about any Democrat they're going to
tell you of course I'm against 38 year
olds being predators and finding 12 year
old girls to meet up with I just don't
think that there's anything right-wing
about that perspective
no no and I absolutely agree with that
and that was not necessarily my point
because of course everybody should
should be on the same side in that
regards but my question is when these
people that are clearly doing have good
motives to to do something to even bring
attention to it how do you
um
and then they come out hey I'm I'm
trolling people I'm being a bigot
whatever it is obviously they don't say
that but how do you kind of reconcile
that
it's a big dissonance because they kind
of talk about that you don't want to
support that you don't want to give them
money but they're also doing good
but the police is also working on
getting I just don't know why you would
feel compelled to give money
what are you even giving the money for I
just don't even get it I mean maybe I
just don't understand the whole movement
but I would in my mind I would go oh
these are people whose political views I
find completely deplorable and it's a
good thing to get child Predators uh out
of situations where they can be
Predators period I mean I think that's
just it I don't then go how can I donate
money but they hate Jews and what do I I
just I just wouldn't give them any money
there are other ways to deal with
um you know people people being targeted
by Predators or trafficked or whatever
the case may be you don't have to give
you know some right-wing guy with a with
a cell phone money to do it
I understand okay awesome and thank you
for for that and sorry I wasn't very
clear but no that's okay and uh have a
wonderful day all right you too there is
Rick from Texas with a very powerful
topic for sure why don't we go next to
uh Dylan in Georgia is it do I have this
right it's a series of names Dylan in
Georgia yes welcome Dylan
hey David can you hear me yes I can
oh fantastic this is my first
time oh boy and you're it's your first
time on but your audio is already going
uh completely digital and nuclear
sounds
right yeah I'm in pretty real part of
the day right now okay all right Dylan
I'm gonna have to let you go because you
sound like a robot on a cartoon so I'm
gonna have to let you go that's just
it's not working unfortunately and I
know the audience will be very very
displeased with me let's go to Marcus
from Sacramento Marcus from Sacramento
welcome to the program what can I do for
you today
Marcus from Sacramento you're muted by
your own doing please unmute yourself
and then you'll be able to talk to me
uh hello David hi
hey so I'm uh I'm obviously from
California and I'm a big fan of uh Gavin
Newsom our governor and he said a few
months ago that uh it's time for us to
kind of stop with the whole they go low
we go high routine
um how do you feel about uh Democrats
becoming more I guess ruthless just like
the Republicans are in order to get uh
things done I played the clip of Gavin
Newsom saying that when he said it I
completely agree with it now when I when
I talked about this I made a sort of a
distinction I guess I would say Marcus
which is I don't think
that what Democrats need to start doing
is lying deceiving cheating criminality
like we shouldn't be stooping to what
the right is doing but when it comes to
being ruthless with regard to using
stronger language adopting particular
tones targeting with aggressive ads when
when Republicans have done things all
these all the things that Newsome is
suggesting
we we absolutely should do it I don't
believe that that is quote stooping to
their level I think stooping to their
level would be overtly lying to try to
get policies passed that are terrible
for the American people but good for
their friends right like that's what
they do we shouldn't do that but when it
comes to language tone and strategy in
the way that Newsome is suggesting
ruthlessness I'm with it a hundred
percent
I also had one last question we're
noticing lately people like Tucker
Carlson Ben Shapiro they're trying to
essentially downplay uh January 6th and
yeah my thoughts are
um that they uh that January 6 is
working like our strategy of using
January 6 is working and uh they're
starting to go hey we need to downplay
it because it's just this is an
effective strategy yeah how do you feel
about using that I think to some degree
that's true but at the same time the
longer it is since the January 6 Trump
riots I think the more diminished the
effectiveness will be I don't for
example I don't know that in 2024
talking about the Trump riots will be
super effective for whoever is
ultimately the Democratic nominee I may
be wrong about that but I feel like its
power will will diminish over time
awesome well thank you so much for
having me on what's going on in the
background by the way Marcus do you run
a daycare are those your kids
I'm a work from home stay at home dad so
sorry about that no no no no problem it
sounds uh sounds active for lack of a
better term
yeah there are five and and two right
now so it's uh it's it's really fun so
all right I take your word for it sounds
hectic but uh someday I might be there
all right Marcus thank you for the call
thank you Dave ticker all right there it
goes Marcus from Sacramento let's go
next to oh I don't know how about Jason
from Virginia who's also a website
member Jason thank you for being a a
member at joinpakman.com I appreciate
that
hey yeah Dave I've been a member for a
couple years now I always put your show
on and uh go out for a run and uh nice
you know just like following along him I
appreciate everything I have kind of
like a David packman conspiracy theory
that I've been formulating uh-oh so yeah
yeah so uh oh maybe 21 you had gone to
YouTube headquarters is that right
um yeah
2021 right yeah that's when my
girlfriend got coveted on that trip yep
you're absolutely correct okay and then
like during that wasn't it on the flight
home you sat next to Alex Jones lawyer
of some sort no toots so that the
sitting next to Alex Jones former lawyer
was on a different trip back from Vegas
okay because I was trying to put that
all together and then because shortly
thereafter then it was the famous Alex
Jones attack so I had just uh kind of no
and you know what the timing of it is
Alex Jones went after me before I sat
next to his former lawyer because I
talked about that with his lawyer so the
timing you just have the timing a little
bit off oh okay all right yeah I was
just sitting and reflecting on it but uh
what a Priceless story it really is
quite a story and there may be more
stories coming let's put it that way oh
all right well thank you so much all
right thanks Jason there's Jason just uh
you know it's sad when a good conspiracy
theory gets sort of interrupted by the
facts particularly when it would be such
an entertaining one but what can I do
let's go to Samir from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Samir welcome to the
program let's hope that the tech gods
have given you a good connection today
Samir welcome
can you hear me yes
all right David I I watched your uh your
show with that guy Patrick in Florida
Patrick Bet David yes
yeah and um in his uh during the
interview I don't think if you notice
but he totally contradicted himself
which of the hundred times are you
referring to
right right uh specifically he said well
the United States should be run like a
company
and and as a company the the United
States would do much better because you
know whatever vs excuse he came up with
but then he said that
um uh
he specifically said that
um that he mentioned something about
millionaires
um being very powerful and then I'm
thinking like does he not realize if the
United States will run like millionaire
like a company they would eliminate
millionaires because that would be their
competition
uh I don't know that I understand if the
United States were run like a company
they would eliminate millionaires
yeah because he was saying about when
you were working at Circuit City that
um the Circuit City came in and changed
the policy and got rid of all the eye
paying people and kept all the
low-paying people yeah and that he went
uh socialism for that I don't know how
he blamed socialism but he blamed
socialism with that and then he said
well the United States should be run
like a company like Circuit City well if
the United States were very much a
company like Circuit City and Circuit
City got rid of all of their high-paying
people right wouldn't the United States
then get rid of all the Millionaires and
billionaires but he said that it was
wrong to do that so no I don't think no
I don't listen here's the thing Samir
maybe I'm just having trouble following
this but but here's what I would say
you're doing something that's really
difficult which is you're trying to
analogize provide context and find the
internal logic of things that make no
sense whatsoever and that can be really
difficult to do because a lot of the
stuff that Patrick said during the
interview made no sense and so while
it's a it's a worthwhile attempt to make
it's really tough to make sense and even
analogize the things he said because
they were so nonsensical and I came away
as confused by it as it sounds like you
did
um my next my last question is if um if
Trump were to run third party do you
think
um it would be helpful if Bernie ran
third party or helpful to who
uh the Democrats or for Bernie no if
Bernie ran third party he would take
votes from the Democratic nominee and
might end up uh leading to the
Democratic nominee losing that's why I
hope Trump does run third party
I see I see okay well thank you for
taking my call uh David I love your show
and I watch it all the time thank you
Samir from Pittsburgh very much
appreciate it great to hear from you
let's go next to oh I don't know how
about uh there's a lot of people very
very anxious to get on let's go to David
from Texas David welcome to the program
what's on your mind
David from Texas
baby can you hear me yes I can
okay thanks David man I've been
listening to you for a year and uh
really I've learned a lot and I like to
listen to you and Brian Tyler Cohen and
my story is basically that I was
conservative for 60 years and I retired
from coaching and teaching calculus and
I decided I better learn uh all the
history and things that I didn't know as
a young person
and so um I was married to a uh still am
married to a Mexican-American woman and
we adopted
for Mexican-American children so I've
kind of come out of the bubble and my
wife tells me that I was in a bubble for
a long time so that's a super
interesting laugh and do you do you live
in like do you live in a city in Texas
or do you live more rurally Leo I live
west of Dallas about three hours and
about two hours south of Lubbock okay so
it's not it's not it's like a Suburban
environment so to speak
and it's like 12 000 people oh okay
interesting so it's a little and there's
a there's a town about we're close to
Abilene about an hour from Abilene
fascinating and so you just came across
at this stage in your life a total
revision of your political views
definitely
um in my two two of my four children
have really helped me because they are
very
uh liberal and live in bigger cities and
have you know they work in Tech and in
city government and right so they have a
lot of views that have you know helped
me with my new views and my 94 year old
mother and I have been able to spend
time together
in the last few years and shaving very
very conservative
um you know is
still holding out a lot of her
conservative views although I would say
that she's a lot more liberal than she
thinks she is but for example in the
last presidential election as long as
abortion was on top of the the list up
there she was going to be and probably
still always real well conservative but
as we have our conversations
um we have come to find out I've come to
find out that she's a lot more liberal
than she would think here's just one
example I've got so many things I could
talk to you about but let me just tell
you since my four children are adopted
my mother would always say how can you
be
uh I you know for abortion you know uh
and so whenever people would ask me that
you know how can you be for abortion or
want a woman to have the right to choose
yep
um then you know my answer now is much
like Jamie Lee Curtis I think it was it
said the other night on the Oscars is
that Americans have been able to choose
how and how many and when they want to
raise children and adoption is pretty
much exactly tailored in that way we
were able to not only choose when we
wanted to have children how many we
wanted we were able to choose the sex of
the of the children so we have two boys
and two girls
and so that's kind of now my standard
answer is you know it's a choice it
really is you should be able to choose
when you want to have children well said
well said well David's from Texas very
much appreciated and uh thanks for
sharing what is a very interesting story
well thanks a lot Brian all right David
from Texas
appreciate it did he just call me Ryan
that was I think you might just call me
or Brian did he think he was talking to
Brian Tyler Cohen right there what just
happened I I went over it and now I'm
realizing I think he called me Brian uh
all right let's clip that out we got to
look at that really closely listen to it
like there's a Pruder film and figure
out what happened thank you everybody
who called in we're going to take a
break I'll take calls again very soon
all right let's do Friday feedback or
the Feed Bag Friday or you know you all
know what it is all right let's get
right into it Steve wrote in Steve had
some unkind words to say about the show
as if someone is forcing him to watch
Steve writes you are one uninformed
uneducated POS stupid mother effer Trump
will win be quays people know how effing
corrupt and treasonous the left-wing
lunatics and the media like you ftard
really is I think you mean really are
Steve I think you mean really are
um yeah you know it's interesting it's
either they call you uneducated or they
say well you're educated but the
education is a liberal
indoctrination which is it Steve please
tell me exactly which one of the two it
is now on Trump will win
remember these are the same people who
were insisting Trump will win in 2020
and then Trump lost and now they go well
he actually did win so they're not
exactly folks who who will revise their
claims or predictions if it were not to
come to pass just an important thing to
keep in mind there's no way to have a
good faith discussion with folks like
that uh trist oh there were people who
came so this this always happens during
election season
I will live stream an event
and the event might be a Donald Trump
event like I streamed the Trump CPAC
speech and people are just looking for
the speech they don't know who I am they
find my stream and they watch and they
see that some of my commentary is less
than glowing about Donald Trump and then
they write to me one such person is
Tristan who wrote To Me and said
oh no this is not an example of that
we'll get to that this is actually a
different type of email okay Tristan
wrote to me and said dear David watching
your live stream of Donald Trump's rally
what is shocking to me is that I am
excited by the entertainment value
of trump being back on Center Stage I
could not hate him more but it's
fascinating how the hatred of him is
entertaining Tristan
I heard from a bunch of people on the
left about this saying to me David you
know
I really couldn't think Trump was any
worse for the world it's it's a disaster
his ideas are terrible his lack of
decorum the way he is debased politics
it's all horrible
but it's so damn funny to watch him give
these speeches where he glitches and
gets confused and says insane things and
it's just it's like a disaster porn of
sorts here's my take on that
I would say that as long as you're
voting and you're working to improve the
situation in the United States
I don't think that you're doing
something wrong by being entertained by
the insanity assuming you never lose
sight of the reality that left unchecked
meaning if Trump becomes president it's
really really bad for the world in the
country as long as that context is there
there is an entertaining layer to the
insanity of trump that's sort of where I
would leave it from the subreddit user
bug operator wrote have voter fraud
conspiracy theorists ever offered a
reason as to why voting machine
companies wanted Trump to lose I mean
motive is one of the three main elements
of a crime yet I've never actually heard
anyone accusing dominion and smartmatic
of fraud explain why they would have
wanted to rig the election for Biden
what could they possibly have had to
gain by doing this I highly doubt
they're just anarchists who wanted to
create chaos for the hell of it so
what's the actual reason behind the
conspiracy I know it's asking a lot to
assume these people even have a reason
but I'm curious if anything even
remotely resembling a motive has ever
been put forth so what I've it's a
really good question which is if you're
smartmatic or your Dominion voting
systems why would you have a preference
for one candidate over another your if
profit is your motive your preference
would be that your machines are used
more and more
and so doing something that risks
exposing you in some way or what none of
it makes any sense the best claim I've
seen made from the people who believe
this nonsense is that the voting machine
companies are owned by or controlled by
democrats so that the the companies
themselves are a tool
for Democrats to win elections that's
the best thing I've heard and obviously
there's no evidence that that took place
um okay
I spoke last week about how it would be
a good thing for us to have more
non-lawyers as presidents of the United
States and in general in politics and
Houdini did it commented on YouTube the
biggest issue with non-lawyers is that
our government is about law from Obama
to Raskin to Bernie to Jeffries having
depth and understanding of law makes all
the difference on the floor and in
debates just look at how Marjorie Taylor
green and Beau Bert or Beau bear
are constantly torn to shreds we don't
need the Democratic equivalent
um that is interesting now I have to
look something up is Bernie a lawyer I I
think I actually don't know that about
Bernie education Brooklyn College
University of Chicago bachelor's degree
um yeah so burnt Bernie's not a lawyer
that that what's interesting about this
is the argument that's being made here
which is
these lawyers are better is that this
this person is listening Bernie who is
not a lawyer
so if anything it seems to me to prove
that it would be fine and a good thing
to have more non-lawyers now I am not so
naive that I believe
every uh field every career makes one
well set up to be an elected official or
president of the United States I'm not
arguing that what I am arguing is that
we don't have nearly enough uh a broad
representation of career types
um in government and I would like to see
that uh changed s strange commented when
I borrowed my brother-in-law's Maga hat
back in 2016. I pointed out the made in
China tag and the irony his response and
I'm not kidding was that just means
Trump is smart he makes more money that
way I shook my head in disbelief well
shaking's one head in disbelief is a
common and reasonable reaction
um too much of what these hypocritical
right-wingers do and this little uh
exchange that this person is recounting
is emblematic of why I'm increasingly
convinced that as a wholesale strategy
for winning elections convincing people
like this simply isn't going to work and
the reason is as as is pointed out here
they come up with some initial statement
well listen we gotta stop with the made
in China stuff we've got to bring back
our make stuff domestically and bring
back the supply chains and all of this
oh okay well the guy who you follow is
manufacturing stuff in China that oh
well that he's smarter for doing that
I'm sure he pays less money
you are not going to be able to win
these people over by exposing the double
standard in hypocrisy of the failure to
adhere to principles you're not going to
and so as a personal thing if you enjoy
trying to change the minds of people
like this by all means have added I have
said before and I will say again I don't
think that it will help us win elections
because I don't know at the wholesale
level how you deal with that dog Hollow
weighed in about Mitt Romney and says
we're at a point where Mitt Romney has
become a voice of reason in the
Republican party I have to admit I've
grown to respect him I remember when he
was in big trouble for putting his dog
kennel on top of his car and just a bad
choice now I would have given anything
for him to be president instead of trump
everything is relative yeah I think that
the reason this is uh well said is
oftentimes when I'll mention something
about even George Bush wouldn't or Mitt
Romney this or that I'll get some
messages from people saying oh you're
like glorifying these people you're
rehabilitating them no no no no it's not
that I'm rehabilitating them I still see
them as I did before it's just that
compared to trumpism they aren't as bad
right and so when we think about Mitt
Romney yeah Mitt Romney as a Mormon is a
social conservative and as views I don't
agree with but the guy marched with
black lives matter he has gone after a
lot of these hate movements from the
right would I disagree with Mitt Romney
about tax policy of course would Mitt
Romney likely try to cut Social programs
that I would like to expand rather than
cut yes but their differences of a
different category to a great degree uh
than much of what we are seeing with
trumpism which is just unhinged insanity
um a user from our subreddit asks is
David playing Billiards on the new set
last couple of days there has been a
noise in the background of the podcast
that sounds like a pool like a pool
table is David running a pool hall out
of his new studio are there dart boards
is it possible someone is running a
lathe you have you know when you when
you build a new studio
which we did
there are often little things that don't
go quite right I'll give you an example
with my chair see I'm in a chair I'm not
standing during the show with the chair
that I use
where I re it has adjustable armrests
where I really want the arm rests I just
put it is a little bit higher than where
I have them set but the problem is
there's a glitch with the left arm rest
button where if I put too much weight on
it okay
it goes down one click and so honestly I
don't even know how it keeps getting up
to that top top setting but what
sometimes will happen is that it will be
set there and I'll shift my weight and
then it'll make a Gunk okay of sorts the
other issue is that as a result of the
arm rests not being where I want them
there's an issue where they make contact
with the desk and sometimes
there will be another noise we're
working on every one of these things
believe me they bother me as much as or
more than they bother you but there are
no Billiards being played we're not
running any power tools here
um nor are we uh nor are there dart
boards or anything like that but I I do
appreciate the concern all right you can
email info davidpackman.com if you have
something to say for Friday feedback
sometimes we'll take a YouTube comment
sometimes we'll take a Twitter reply or
a Facebook message or whatever the case
may be just remember if you interact
with the show what you say may become
part of the show with identifying
information of course respectfully
removed we have a fantastic bonus show
today Pat's out this week so you'll have
me for the Friday bonus show much to the
pleasure or dismay of different people
in the audience depending on your
preference sign up at joinpakman.com
I'll see you then
thank you